alors mes chers collègues après monsieur
fabrice lenglart la semaine dernière sur
le revenu universel d'activité nous
entendons ce matin monsieur gilbert 7
président du groupe d'experts sur le
smic qu'elle souhaitait être entendu en
visioconférence ça devait être en
présentiel mais
nous le faisons en visio donc je salue
nos collègues qui participe également à
nos travaux en visio j'indique que cette
audition fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo retransmise en direct sur le site
du sénat qui sera ensuite disponible en
vidéo à la demande dans notre pays les
dispositifs de soutien à l'emploi le
revenu des travailleurs aux salaires les
plus bas sont nombreux et variés
qu'il s'agisse des allègements généraux
de cotisations
de la prime d'activité ou encore de la
revalorisation du smic au cours de la
période récente
le gouvernement a privilégié des
dispositifs comme la prime l'activité
qui sont coûteux pour les finances
publiques
chaque année le groupe d'experts se
prononce sur la revalorisation du
salaire minimum au 1er janvier
dans un rapport remis au gouvernement le
15 décembre dernier que vous trouverez
sur demeter le groupe d'experts
recommande de s'abstenir de tout coup de
pouce sur le smic au 1er janvier 2022 le
salaire minimum est en revalorisé selon
des mécanismes automatiques que le
groupe recommande par ailleurs de
réviser
dans ce même rapport le groupe indique
je cite que les politiques de soutien
aux bas revenus ont atteint également
leurs limites dès 2019 dans la mesure où
la mobilité dans le bas de la
distribution des salaires et la
formation des salariés concernés qui la
permet ont perdu de leur rendement en
termes de revenus nous sommes intéressés
par ce point mais aussi par l'ensemble
des sujets d'actualité sur cette
question les tensions sur le marché du
travail malgré un taux de chômage encore
élevé
l'inflation et les revendications
salariales qui se font jour dans
certains secteurs comme
l'agroalimentaire
mais aussi les effets de la crise et des
mesures de soutien aux entreprises
plus largement quelles sont selon votre
groupe d'experts les bons outils pour
soutenir l'emploi et le revenu des
travailleurs pauvres
je vous laisse la parole avant que le
débat ne s'engage avec les commissaires
qui souhaite vous interroger
notamment nous rapporteur budgétaire sur
la mission travail et emploi et
solidarité que sont frédéric puis ça et
gens seuls je vous laisse la parole
monsieur 7
merci beaucoup
j'espère donc que vous m'entendez bien
je vais commencer par un propos
liminaire à notre invitation
et bien sûr en huit ans le maximum d'eux
de place ensuite à la discussion et à
vos questions donc vous savez tous et je
vous remercie beaucoup de cette audition
parce que j'en suis très content parce
qu'il me semble important de vous rendre
compte des réflexions de ce groupe
d'experts et audacieux ou d'experts
d'ailleurs d'une très grande fraction de
la communauté des économistes et des
personnes qui s'intéressent à ces
questions voilà depuis désolé de ne pas
avoir pu venir mais j'ai subi une petite
intervention chirurgicale ya peu de
temps et donc en mobilité et la série no
8 points quand cette intervention
liminaire lui point rapide
avant de répondre à vos questions
premier point dans un pays comme la
france
comme dans d'autres pays où la
négociation collective
est assez faible le pouvoir de
négociation des salariés est assez
faible un salaire minimum national le
smic chez nous est indispensable
alors ça peut aller de soi pour beaucoup
d'entre vous mais il faut quand même
rappeler que les pays dans lesquels les
inégalités sont les plus faibles
sur des piles ans qu'elle n'y a pas de
salaire minimum national et je pense par
exemple aux pays nordiques et
scandinaves dans les pays nordiques et
scandinaves il n'y a pas d'équivalent de
notre smic il n'y a pas de salaire
minimum national
et quand un débat souvent sur le salaire
minimum national dans ces pays là ce
sont les syndicats de salariés qui s'y
opposent avec la plus grande énergie en
dix ans laissez nous faire notre boulot
c'est à nous de négocier les salaires et
l'établissement d'un salaire minimum
national nous affaiblir vous voyez on
est dans des mondes très différents dans
des pays comme la france ou l'allemagne
et puis à des pays comme les pays
nordiques et scandinaves ou j'appelle
les inégalités de revenus de patrimoine
sont beaucoup plus faible que chez un
grand pays voisin l'italie n'a pas non
plus de salaire minimum national et en
italie également ce sont les syndicats
de salariés qui s'y opposent avec les
mêmes arguments que ceux que je viens
d'évoquer donc l'existence d'un salaire
minimum national notre smic est
indispensable mais est indispensable
parce qu'il est le reflet de la
faiblesse quelque sorte de la
négociation collective et où est la
poule où il a fait évidemment cette
célèbre minimum national affaibli
[Musique]
déresponsabilisant partie les acteurs de
la négociation plex deuxième point de
cette intervention liminaire devrait
souligner la sur ce point là il ya il ya
un grand consensus et ce diagnostic est
basée sur de multiples simulations qui
ont été faites sur des échantillons de
centaines de milliers de ménages on en a
emporté les résultats dans plusieurs de
nos rapports du groupe d'experts
le salaire minimum le smic chez nous est
inefficace pour lutter contre la
pauvreté
d'autres outils sont beaucoup plus
efficaces que le salaire minimum alors
pourquoi la première raison c'est que
quand on regarde attentivement
quels sont les principaux facteurs de
pauvreté en france comme dans d'autres
pays un dans ce que je vous dit il n'y a
rien de spécifique à la france on voit
que le principal facteur de pauvres et
c'est le nombre d'heures travaillées
est donc le moyen le plus efficace pour
lutter contre la pauvreté c'est
d'augmenter le nombre d'heures
travaillées
des ports
enfin dans les pauvres sont sur
représentés bien sûr les personnes sans
emploi les personnes en temps partiel
contraint les personnes qui connaissent
des carrières hachées vous voyez ce type
de de ménage et puis le deuxième facteur
après de nombreuses heures travaillées
le deuxième facteur qui explique
statistiquement la pauvreté c'est la
situation familiale évidemment pourra
même revenu et est tout de même si on te
rends compte évidemment les aides de
l'état qui sont fortes en france
on a plus de chance ma chance d'être
pauvre quand on a quatre bouches à
nourrir avec un seul revenu que quand on
a une seule bouche à nourrir et par
exemple les parents célibataires
sont sur représentés parmi les pauvres
et on enquête que très souvent il s'agit
bien évidemment de mères célibataires
donc inefficacité et puis inefficacité
aussi par ailleurs par le fait que
quelqu'un est au smic mais peut vivre
avec une autre personne qui est loin du
smic
voyez dans un foyer fiscal est donc dans
ce cas là l'augmentation du smic ne
réduira pas ne contribuera pas à réduire
la pauvreté alors quels sont les leviers
les plus efficaces pour lutter contre la
pauvreté j'ai dit le nombre d'heures
travaillées et montrent que la réduction
du chômage
le combat contre le le temps partiel
contraint contre les carrières hachées
et puis par ailleurs le soutien aux bas
revenus et les soutien aux bas revenus
situés et la prime l'activité quand on
parle de pauvreté laborieuse la prime
une activité est un outil très efficace
de lutte contre la pauvreté en france
vous le savez la prime activité très
importante pour vous donner un ordre de
grandeur un salarié célibataire au smic
à temps plein
à une prime d'activité mensuel d'environ
on a en disant un petit peu 280 euros
par mois quelque chose d'assez
conséquent par rapport à son seul revenu
du travail du smic ici à tremplin viard
y ait une augmentation de 15 à 20 % de
son revenu est de son volume d'activité
puisque si j'ose dire la primitivité par
définition il y aller puis à d'autres
scènes bien sûr qu'ils soutiennent le
revenu des moins avancés et en
particulier dans un pays comme le nôtre
les aides au logement
cette efficacité plus grande de la prime
d'activité que le salaire minimum pour
lutter contre la pauvreté et la pauvreté
laborieuse a été montré par de multiples
simulations publiées dans le rapport une
simulation qui sont factuels et
d'ailleurs on a été entendu puisque
comme vous savez ces landais une des
décisions la forte revalorisation la
prime l'activité qui a été prise fin
2018 et 2019 pour répondre en partie
mouvement des dg les jeux c'est par ce
moyen qui a été décidé de lutter contre
la pauvreté la borne
troisième point
quand on se compare à d'autres pays on
constate que le smic est assez le
salaire minimum en france est assez
élevée que malgré la baisse
des charges sociales employeurs ciblés
au niveau du smic voyait entre arabes et
sismique il ya malgré cette baisse
malgré ces exonérations
notre service minimum en termes de coût
pour les entreprises est l'un des plus
élevés parmi tous les pays avancés vous
envoie la
donne et qui sont moins la page 54 de
notre dernier rapport mais par ailleurs
compte tenu de l'importance des
dispositifs qui sont déployés dans notre
pays il en france pour soutenir le
revenu des personnes
la rue
on observe une quelque chose qui est
très très particulier à la france c'est
que la mobilité sociale et la mobilité
salariale rapporte peu je vous donner un
chiffre
ça peut sembler complexe l'explication
de ce chiffre mais sur le fond c'est
assez simple le ratio entre le revenu
d'un salarié célibataire à temps plein
au smic et le revenu du même salarié
célibataire à temps plein mais au
salaire médian mediobanca autant de
ménages qui gagnent moins que le ménage
qui gagne +1 en salaire bien ce ratio
est de 80% ventes plus élevées que dans
tous les autres pays de céder
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que quand un salarié qui
est au plus bas de l'échelle des
salaires un salarié travaillant à temps
plein célibataire le plus bas à
l'échelle des salaires
sacrifie voyez des soirées et week-ends
et vacances pour pour se former et
traversé par une mobilité salariale la
moitié de la distribution des salaires
pour les du plus bas jusqu'au célèbre
médian c'est quand même une épopée 1 eh
bien ils sont revenus passe de 80 à 100
c'est à dire une augmentation de 25% ce
qui est assez faible par rapport à tous
les autres pays et pourquoi
ce foration 80% et bien parce qu'on a
beaucoup de dispositifs de soutien aux
bas revenus comme la prime l'activité
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure mais elle
a beaucoup d'autres en france qui sont
bien évidemment
dégressif avec 0 de l'activité pour
éviter d'être trop cher et ne sont pas
universels envoyé le soutien aux bas
revenus est quelque chose qui a aussi
des conséquences des conséquences qui ne
sont pas que positive certes sa lutte
efficacement contre la pauvreté mais
simultanément
ça réduit
tirer les gars de la mobilité salariale
et de la mobilité sociale quatrième
point nous sommes en france et on le dit
on le répète dans le rapport du groupe
d'experts au monde d'une certaine
logique qui a été amorcée au début des
années 90 et qui a été prolongé par tous
les gouvernements qui soit de gauche de
droite voyez sur ce plan là il y à
vraiment
continuité des politiques ses collègues
ses politiques donc sur lesquels on est
au bout du chemin qu'on a complètement
épuisé maintenant sont deux politiques
d'une part la baisse du coût du travail
au niveau du smic via des baisses de
cotisations sociales au niveau parce
qu'il ne reste plus rien ou quasiment
que rien n'y a plus que les
contributions accidents du travail
maladies professionnelles
que personne ne pense à à réduire
puisqu'elles sont assortis d'un bonus
malus ce qui se veut incitatif pour de
bon comportement des des entreprises et
donc là on est au jugement entamée au
début des années 90 et puis on est au
bout du chemin c'est dans le soutien aux
bas revenus via les dispositifs comme la
prime d'activité pourquoi au bout du
chemin bien parce que c'est c'est le
chiffre que je vous ai donné tout à
l'heure on a déjà évidemment des
incitations trop faible à la mobilité
salariale à la mobilité sociale au
développement du une certaine énergie
voyez pour faire valoir et des ambitions
de la part de beaucoup ça va beaucoup de
salariés et donc c'est fini c'est
derrière nous ça veut dire quoi cela
veut dire que maintenant le soutien aux
bas revenus la politique politiques
idoines déployés pour les bas revenus
devront se baser sur d'autres outils et
ses autres outils c'est quoi ça va être
la négociation collective
nécessairement une émotion collective
qui a connu bien sûr un gros boost par
les ordonnances travail de septembre
2010 elle est parée loi punit col de
mars 2018 dans l' architecture si vous
voulez qu'on qu'on peut voir deux skiffs
l évolution des bd des salaires des bas
salaires le smig indispensable et d'un
socle ils vont le rester et à côté de ça
il y a les minima de branche qui sont
négociés par les partenaires sociaux et
qui prenne en compte au niveau de la
branche des réalités les activités de la
pénibilité des conditions de travail des
attentes des salariés etc et puis
ensuite il ya la négociation bien sûr
d'entreprise qui prend acte des minois
d'ange
résultant de la négociation prix
cinquième point de cette intervention
une fois qu'on a dit ça on objets
constater et ça a été fortement souligné
leur débat public sur les dernières
semaines que de nombreux munis
malebranche sont inférieures au sud
alors bien sûr dans notre pays
heureusement le smic étant une
disposition tantôt public quand un
minima de branche des inférieurs au smic
aucun salarié n'est payé en dessous du
smic
[Musique]
ça va de soi encore heureux mais
néanmoins ça comme conséquence de tasser
l'éventail des salaires
des salariés et puis avec un un plus
pour ceux qui sont soupçonnés de tasser
l'éventail des salaires et donc
d'augmenter la masse salariale qui est
éligible aux allègements de cotisations
sociales
pour être clair avec pour parler un coup
de plus cash ça aboutit à une et en
slovénie moins de recettes ce qui
revient au même c'est à dire que les
branches et des entreprises de ses
branches gagnent
[Musique]
à faire en sorte que
les minima de branche soit inférieur au
smic alors je dis pas qu'elles font ça
pour ce gamin néanmoins on vit dans une
situation où il ya cette incitation
négative à la négociation collective les
entreprises d'une branche gagne 6 limina
dans cette branche sont inférieurs au
smic donc il faut absolument se sera
peut-être
partie de notre débat tout cas leur faut
absolument faire en sorte que les mines
marc bien sûr soit calé au minimum sur
le smic mais qui ne soit pas inférieure
au smic est aujourd'hui dans la
négociation payes tu te venge on peut
faire ce constat alors même alors même
que les difficultés de recrutement que
vous connaissez bien vous avez ok madame
tout à leurs biens font que le rapport
de force dans la négociation collective
est quand même favorable à la partie
salariale bien malgré ça on observera
midan nombreux proches que j'ai évoqué
un sixième point en france le salaire
minimum
est très contraint en termes de
revalorisations
il n'y a pas d'équivalent dans tous les
autres pays avancent aucun équipement
voyant france est un processus de
revalorisation automatique une
indexation sur l'inflation plus une
indexation sur la moitié des gains de
pouvoir d'achat d'un index salariale de
salaire horaire de base des ouvriers des
employés
plus éventuellement un coup de pouce et
le groupe d'experts sur le smic que j'ai
l'honneur de présider ne doit une
recommandation que sur ce dernier point
en termes de revalorisations
très souvent une confusion des débats
les 10 le groupe d'experts ne recommande
pas de l'augmentation du smig et j'en
suis la ministre le ministre n'augmente
pas le smic c'est faux le smic augmente
de façon automatique et bien sûr les
choix qui peuvent être faits concernent
le coup de pouce donc quasiment tous les
autres pays avancés
la revalorisation du salaire minimum est
quelque chose de totalement
discrétionnaire pour les parcs publics
qui peut s'appuyer pour cette décision
sur la vie éventuelle d'une commission
et qu'il allait au niveau d'experts que
je préside voiliers a pas d'équivalent
en france et c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs on on a
préconisé ne compte d'experts ce mec que
je préside a préconisé à plusieurs
reprises le fait de se rapprocher les
autres pays de devenir un pays normal
dire d'enlever ces dispositifs
automatiques pour que locaux d'espérer
attention dans sa
le gouvernement dans sa décision et bien
et tout la marche de l'attitude comme
dans les autres pays en fonction de ce
qui se passe sur le marché travail en
fonction de la situation économique est
bien et toute latitude pour décider
quelle sera l'augmentation du salaire
minimum de notre son
septième point dans la crise actuelle
qui s'est passé pour les smicards dans
la crise qu vie
très souvent enfin les smicards sont sur
représentées dans les postes qui ne sont
pas télétravail a
en conséquence
les smicards sont par contre
surreprésentées dans les emplois dits de
première et de deuxième but je n'aime
pas trop ces appellations mais elles
sont facilement compréhensible donc les
cigares sont surreprésentées dans les
emplois de première et deuxième ligne et
les smicards sont également ceux
représentés dans parmi les est salarié
qui ont bénéficié
des dispositifs d'activité partielle
avec une protection particulière pour
les personnes au smic puisque vous savez
que pour eux la
l'indemnisation était à couvrir
intégralement à 100%
des suites vous pouvez pas être
inférieur au smic si bien que les
berceaux semis n'ont pas connu dans
l'activité partielle de baisse de leur
pouvoir d'achat pour une protection
spécifique les concernant
et puis dernier point de ce propos
liminaire quand on regarde autour de
nous qu'est ce qui se passe pour le
semis d'avoir où on peut constater que
la france est est l'un des pays dans
lequel le salaire minimum a le plus
progressé
comparé aux autres pays sur l'année 2021
avec des arguments automatique de façon
automatique certes elles puissent
progresser
1% au 1er janvier
2021 2 2% au 1er octobre à 2021 3 2% en
année il ya très peu de pays qui ont
fait plus ça c'est le premier constat
qu'on peut faire dans le débat sur le
salaire minimum certains pays envisagent
de fortement augmenter leur salaire
minimum c'est qu'à l'allemagne par
exemple qui avec la nouvelle coalition
au pouvoir envisage de porter à à 12
euros le célèbre homme c'est à dire un
niveau supérieur ou d'autres avec un
calendrier pas encore été précisée par
cette augmentation la
réponse à ça c'est que l'allemagne fait
les choses en ordre
l'allemagne est un pays dans lequel le
taux de chômage à 3% le nôtre d'appui
pour cent la langue est un pays très
compétitif son excédent de balance
courante est de 9% du film quand nous
nous sommes en déficit pour la quinzième
année consécutive ce qui manifeste
évidemment ce qui témoigne d'un manque
de compétitivité et donc l'allemagne
fait les choses dans l'ordre alors
parfois donc déjà il évoqué
l'augmentation très forte du salaire
minimum qui est lui en espagne en 2019
pour dire vous voyez il ya d'autres pays
qui tient au monde fortement notre
salaire minimum alors certes bon chemin
l'espagnole même après cette forte
augmentation est inférieure aux 2 autres
un fou quand même le rappeler et puis
bon on s'est penché sur les conséquences
de cette forte augmentation du salaire
minimum en espagne et une seule étude
approfondie
qui a été fait par des économistes
académique de la banque d'espagne
communiste connu et reconnu
parmi tous les la donne ta communauté
les économistes du marché du travail
c'est la seule étude approfondie qui est
fait sur les conséquences de cette
augmentation de 20% à peu près le
salaire minimum espagne les résultats de
cette étude sont qu'en espagne ça aurait
détruit la même année 2010 9 entre 90 et
100 88 emplois l'essai s'est des
conséquences fortes leur simple pour
ceux qui ont gardé leur emploi ou c'est
le minimum
une amélioration de leur situation pour
les 90000 à 180 milles personnes au
salaire minimum en espagne qui ont perdu
leur emploi par contre il ya eu très
nettement une détérioration de leur
situation financière donc voilà je suis
allé vite mais malgré cette volonté j'ai
été un petit peu long excusez moi si tu
ouvres lumière que je voulais avoir et
j'espère ne pas vous avoir trop ennuyé
je suis très heureux de répondre à
toutes vos questions
merci monsieur le président nous a été
très clair comme comme à chaque fois que
l'on aux éditions d'ailleurs on remarque
tout à fait personnelle mais merci pour
cette présentation claire et je le
rappelle à nos collègues que le rapport
est sûre d'aimer terre et je passe aussi
de la parole à à frédérique puissat il a
travaillé sur la négociation collective
voilà entre autres versions à la
présidente et merci monsieur le le
président de cette intervention alors je
dois dire que votre rapport que j'ai
relu ce matin mais que je vais relire
avec grande attention au corps après
vous avoir écouté parce que c'est vrai
que le rapport je devais le dire parfois
il faut s'accrocher un pour le lire
parce que il ya effectivement une
foultitude de données et je pense quand
même que il nous fera référence en bien
des points parce qu'il ya des graphiques
il est illustré de façon très précise et
et un grand merci pour le travail qui a
été fait par tous les experts de ce
groupe que vous avez présidé alors moi
je veux dire que je partage pas mal de
vous de vos de vos positions et sans
forcément inverser les rôles mais
question seront plutôt d'ordre
opérationnel
seront au nombre de quatre j'en avais
préparé certaine mais comme finalement
votre intervention les a balayées j'en
ai repréparer d'autres d'abord je
reviens sur la négociation collective on
a bien compris le rôle que vous donniez
à la négociation collective dans vos
préconisations
ceci étant
on a effectivement des ordonnances que
vous avez évoquées qui avait pour
objectif de libérer cette négociation
collective secteur par secteur on
s'aperçoit quand même que les
discussions en cours font que les
représentants des salariés reviennent
toujours à ce qu'on connaissait
préalablement je sais pas si vous avez
vu les positions des uns et des autres
donc finalement de façon opérationnelle
comment est-ce qu'on peut mettre en
oeuvre ces négociations collectives est
est ce que finalement le travail qui est
en cours
et qui est la suite des ordonnances qui
n'ont pas encore pris pleinement leur
leur envol va dans le bon sens où est ce
qu'il ne faut pas aller plus loin ça
c'est la première question la deuxième
question sur la pauvreté on a bien
compris effectivement que l'enjeu c'est
quand même l'augmentation du nombre
d'heures de travail et les situations
familiales qui pouvait interférer sur
les enjeux de pauvreté
vous avez abordé le bonus malus qui va
être mise en place au niveau de
l'assurance chômage de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage et qui va prendre
son essor prochainement de façon un peu
rapide dans votre rapport est-ce que
vous pouvez nous développer à votre sens
l'impact de ce bonus malus sur
effectivement une augmentation du nombre
d'heures de travail et puis toujours
dans les enjeux de pauvreté
c'est vrai que vous abordez mais ce
n'est pas l'objet de votre de votre vos
travaux 1 vous n'abordez pas du tout le
rsa et éventuellement les enjeux de
primes d'activité de rsa et la
différenciation qui peut y avoir entre
l'activité le smic et le rsa pour
effectivement que le rsa ne soit pas une
trappe à pauvreté troisième point en ce
qui concerne effectivement les enjeux de
branche et notamment le fait de calais
n'ont pas le smic sur les branches mais
de travailler sur un minimum de branche
il ya des discussions qui sont en cours
actuellement branche par branche
qui ont été initiées par le gouvernement
quel est votre regard sur l'avancée des
travaux sur ses branches et à ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin d'un point de vue
opérationnel et enfin dernière question
sur ce que vous avez appelé les
travailleurs de premier et deuxième
ligne qui doivent donner lieu à un
rapport et à des préconisations de la
part du du gouvernement vous n'avez pas
du tout abordé les enjeux de formation
que vous abordez dans votre rapport et
qui font qu'à un moment donné ces
travailleurs là ne sont pas du tout ceux
qui captent les formations alors
qu'elles sont préalablement fait pour
cela et qu'elles devraient permettre
effectivement une évolution au delà du
smic de cette catégorie de
2,2 de professionnels dont quel est
votre regard pour qu'on puisse
effectivement libéré la formation pour
ce type de public
très bien je vous laisse répondre un
taux de 7,1 à notre rapporteur
ces questions adam vraiment
fond des choses je veux
en faire qu'une réponse partielle parce
que sinon il nous faudrait des heures
sup comme les questions fort d'un
bien conscient donc je vais essayer de
2,02 géré au mieux sur la première
question et puis d'ailleurs la halle
troisième manche dossiers sont dans le
rouge
les mocistes collectif qu'on la
dynamiser
la mort du processus le processus peut
pas du jour en bas du jour demain passer
d'une situation de faiblesse de la
négociation collective et de symboles à
une situation où la négociation
collective joue complètement son rôle du
shérif les partenaires sociaux se sont
habitués à l'idée que le gouvernement
très souvent les pouvoirs publics qu'ils
ont pu largement se substitue à eux dans
certains et certaines décisions de
certains vols et en particulier dans la
détermination des des plus bas salaires
le fait de les responsabiliser
et les amener à reprendre en main cela
c'est quelque chose qui est l'homme qui
ne sera pas du jour au lendemain c'est
un processus qui doit s'inscrire dans
dont la durée de façon de façon continue
le lan et 2021 n'est pas émaner
anecdotique puisque comme tout la
d'inflation forte bien sûr le processus
de revalorisation automatique du smic a
provoqué la revalorisation de points du
1er octobre 2 2% on n'avait pas vu ça
depuis dix ans années il ya eu beaucoup
de branches en dessous
du niveau du smic je dirais que face à
cela la sensibilité à la chose a été
forte le ministère du travail comme vous
le savez c'est très fortement mobilisés
là dessus via les commissions mixtes
paritaires pour responsabiliser les
partenaires sociaux est-ce que ça suffit
est-ce que ça suffit pas dans ce rapport
nous disons le monde expert dit qu'il
faudrait peut-être avec lui peut-être
aller plus loin et réfléchir à des voix
comme celle qui avait été utilisé en
2008 c'était la loi du mémoire du 3
décembre 2008 l'article 27 martine 28
qui nous disait que quand un minima de
branche est inférieure au smic pendant
une certaine durée c'est que je me
souviens plus exactement des détails et
bien les
réductions les exonérations de
cotisations sociales l'appareil mise à
sion donc des cotisations sociales est
calculé sur ces minima de branche et non
plus sur le son ça des conséquences
financières très fort pour les branches
et d'entreprises et je vous prie de
croire que c'est une incitation très
forte pour la négociation de branche
cet article n'a jamais été mis en
pratique parce qu il était dit que je
serais mis en pratique si le nombre de
branches concernées ne se réduise et pas
de temps et non branche concernée s'est
réduite puis ensuite cet article a été
abrogée en 2013 hélas été abrogée en
2013 pour la raison suivante c'est
beaucoup de gens s'interroger sur sa
constitutionnalité
et pourquoi l'on peut s'interroger sur
sa constitutionnalité mais vous voyez
que ça ça pouvait amener à sanctionner
des entreprises pour une décision qui
n'est pas de leur ressort et sert pour
une décision qui est prise par la
négociation collective de branche les
sharks dur de justifier une pénalisation
pour une décision qui n'est pas de votre
ressort
alors ça sert beaucoup de gens ont
réfléchi j'ai fait la proposition dans
un ou deux papiers par exemple
on donne à des entreprises la
possibilité d'échapper à cette
difficulté en adressant à la cause un
document dans lequel ils s'engagent eux
à respecter dans leur grille salariale
du smic donc voyez
possibilité d'y échapper puis peut-être
d'autres façons de de faire en tout cas
il faut y réfléchir il faut y réfléchir
non seulement parce que cela
dynamiserait mal la négociation
collective mais je dirais que la
représentation nationale que que vous
êtes est tout à fait légitime à le faire
puisque le fait de le part revalorisé
les minima de branche conditions dessous
du smic coûte à la collectivité
puisque ça augmente la masse salariale
et les gym oh le coup allègements de
cotisations sociales donc pour l'intérêt
général pour vous pour les
préoccupations de finances publiques il
est tout à fait légitime de dire
que la représentation nationale doit
intervenir et cette intervention bien
sûr dynamiser la négociation que les
clients mois encore une fois le bon
dispositif n'est pas facile à trouver
cette question constitutionnelle déchets
pas juristes doivent pas de l'opel
considéré à la légère d'envoyer il faut
dynamiser la négociation de branche et
d'entreprise il faut responsabiliser les
partenaires sociaux il faut amener les
syndicats à se dire si notre boulot a
toujours demandé l'augmentation du smic
c'est aussi même boulot négocié dans les
branches et dans les entreprises
à titre personnel est tout à fait en
dehors de ce groupe d'experts je
préconise avec un juriste qui s'appelle
j'appartenais mis des moyens de
responsabiliser davantage mais les
syndicats dans la négociation collective
pour les challenge et un peu plus pour
dynamiser leur leurs actions leurs
rollers à négociations je pourrais vous
en parler mais comme je parle ici au nom
du groupe d'experts voyagé j'ai quelques
comment dirais-je plusieurs à le faire
du côté la pauvreté maintenant vous avez
tout à fait raison
l'ensemble des dispositifs qu'on a des
toits y ait abouti il peut aboutir à des
travaux votés c'est clair à des travaux
pauvreté et puis pour les salariés les
trains passent la même taille qu'un euro
d'augmentation
du salaire de quelqu'un qui est au smic
abouti à quelque chose de très chère
très largement supérieur à 1 euro pour
quelqu'un pour leur faible coût du
travail pour l'entreprise qui emploie
compte tenu de
comment dirais-je de la dégressivité des
allègements de cotisations sociales et
si l'on prend en compte les dispositifs
de soutien au revenu 1 euros
d'augmentation du revenu de quelqu'un
qui est au smic
abouti compte tenu de la dégressivité de
de commande directe dispositif de
soutien aux bas revenus comme la
productivité et d'autres aboutit à une
augmentation du coût du travail encore
plus fort
c'est très très cher donc là il faut
avoir en tête on donne ces chiffres dans
le rapport farran tels que l'ensemble de
ces dispositifs qui lient supplay elle
négocie ce collectif un peu insuffisant
bien abouti c'est clair la prime de
risque de nourrir des trappes à pauvreté
des trains pas à bas salaires et puis
une faible appétence pour les salariés à
la mobilité salariale à la mobilité
sociale parce que ces écouteurs de se
former de faire
je viens d'essayer de bénéficier d'une
mobilité salarial et social ces coûteux
alors vous avez raison on constate que
les salariés au smic ou proches du smi
recours - à la formation professionnelle
que les autres ce qui peut faire plaisir
c'est que dans la crise en 2020 quand la
formation a diminué formation
professionnelle diminué bien à cette
diminution a été plus faible pour les
salariés au smic et proches du smic pour
les autres c'est ce qu'on a dit dans le
rapport sur la base de données qui ont
été rendus par divers services publics
néanmoins on ne peut pas se satisfaire
fortement
pas satisfait du tout que les la
formation dont bénéficient les salariés
au smic proches au smic soit nettement
inférieure à celle à la moyenne la
formation auraient défilé salariés et
donc là il faut faire quelque chose mais
je le rappelle aussi que le gain de la
formation professionnelle via la
mobilité sociale et salariale est faible
pour quelqu'un lance me à cause de
l'accumulation de tous les dispositifs
comme je l'évoquais tout alors c'est un
point qui me paraît important de
souligner sur la réforme de
l'indemnisation chômage
je vais avoir la même pudeur que tout à
l'heure et vous m'en excuserez
on n'est pas
arrivé n'est pas venu dans notre rapport
du groupe d'experts sur ce terrain là
j'en ai beaucoup le vaucluse dans
d'autres travaux dans d'autres
publications
personnelles ou avec des co auteurs j'ai
beaucoup de réserves sur le plan
personnel sur la pertinence du
dispositif de bonus malus je pense qu'on
aurait pu faire des choses beaucoup plus
efficace beaucoup plus simple que bonus
malus yens mirage de ski ce qui a été
conçue aux états unis dans les années 30
alors on aurait pu faire mieux néanmoins
sur ce point là ne m'en veut d'autre ne
m'en voulez pas je réponde à vos
questions dans un autre contexte dans
une autre réunion ou à notre invitation
mais là que je parle au nom du groupe e
à d'experts sur le smic
c'est quelque chose sur lequel nous
n'avons pas statuer non pas
collectivement réfléchit donc voilà je
je ne peux pas aller plus loin sur ce
sur ce terrain voilà j'espère avoir
apporté les éléments de réponse à vos à
vos interrogations
jean sol
il va donc la présidente monsieur
bonjour mais mais mes chers collègues
g33 question globalement à vous poser
s'agissant notamment de la de la prime
d'activité après six ans de de mise en
oeuvre de cette prestation et trois ans
après sa réalisation exceptionnelle de
90 euros 6 1 sauf erreur de ma part est
ce que vous pensez qu'elle atteint ses
objectifs en particulier le pouvoir
d'achat et la lutte contre la pauvreté
et quelle est l'évolution
effective de cette prestation pourriez
vous préconisez la deuxième question
touche à la bonification individuel de
la prime d'activité qui est versée à
partir d'une demi d'un demi-smic de
revenus mensuels que pensez vous de la
proposition d'ouvrir droit cette
bonification dès le premier euro de
revenu professionnel
ensuite serait-il selon-vous pertinent
d'harmoniser les barèmes de la prime
d'activité et de l'impôt sur le revenu
et puis dernière question comment
stipulait aussi stimulé pardon selon
vous la mobilité salariale compte tenu
du faible qu'un pour les salariés entre
le niveau du smic est le salaire médian
donc que vous évoquiez tout à l'heure
merci
monsieur le président
on répondait ensuite on prendra notre
alain merci pour un merci pour ces
questions alors
je dirais que la forte valorisation
que vous avez évoqué la clique
d'activité début de l'année 2019 est
d'ailleurs celle de la modification
c'est cette bonification de diaconu là
très forte revalorisation que vous
évoquez et qui aboutit quand même à
quelque chose qu'il faut dire qu'il faut
rappeler parce que beaucoup aujourd'hui
en parlant du semis mais comment vous
voulez vivre avec ces salaires mensuels
à temps plein quand vous êtes dans une
grande ville de personnes avec un
salaire à temps plein ne viendrait que
cela pourquoi parce que s'ajoutent à
ceux revenus d'activité la prime
d'activité puis à tas d'autres
de tas d'autres dispositifs et pour la
prime d'activité pour un salarié à temps
plein au smic je le rappelle c'est
environ 280 euros par mois c'est si on
ne sait pas c'est pas anecdotique c'est
pas négligeable et puis ça ajoute à ça
les et documents etc a été réalisée très
bien les autres donc logement social et
donc énormément de
devises positives qui sont moins d'être
financièrement
anecdotique alors je dirais que oui ça
remplit ses objectifs
ça améliorerait sa réduit la pauvreté
laborieuse d'une façon beaucoup plus
efficace que j'aurais pu le faire une
augmentation du smic amen dépenses
publiques j'entends c'est ce que nous
allons montrer dans nos simulations
une augmentation du smic coûte à l'état
pourquoi cela coûte à l'état parce que
une augmentation du smic coûte
directement en termes de coût salarial
les salariés qui travaillent dans la
fonction publique qui sont proches du
smic et puis deuxièmement ça augmente
bien sûr la base salariale il est gilles
aux exonérations de contributions
sociales en guinée une augmentation du
smic ou tel état et bien l'augmentation
lacunes d'activité telle qu'elle a été
décidée au début de l'année mise en
pratique au début d'année 2010 9 a eu un
effet à coup lille en team pour les
finances mais
beaucoup plus efficace pour réduire la
pauvreté que une augmentation du sud
donc ça on l'a montré par beaucoup de
simulations qui ont été réalisées par la
direction générale du trésor c'est
quelque chose qui est à mon sens bien
bien établie néanmois et vous soulevez
un quelque chose de
tout à fait juste il ya la situation des
temps partiels
la situation du temps partiel est
dramatique et je pense que dans notre
prochain rapporte d'ailleurs je pense
qu'on n'a pas encore définitivement
poussé décision on en discute élan dans
une semaine je pense qu'on va on va voir
on va se pencher sur la situation du
temps partiel la situation du temps
partiel et des temps partiels contraints
et on pense beaucoup nous tous à
certains salariés certaines salariées
dans la récup et la caissière de
supermarché qui en temps partiel
contraint avec une forte tendu il s'agit
du travail qui peut être mère
célibataire et c'est une situation
terrible et la modification comme vous
le dites s'amorce à partir d'un derniers
temps il ya quelque chose ici de est
purement ensuite ce qui veut dire que
même quelqu'un qui travaille 24 heures
par semaine et bien être très faible
modifications c'est une modification par
rapport à un salarié à temps plein au
smi il est clair que cette situation à
une terrible et qu'il faut la la
regarder de près tiens que dans ce
domaine là
il faut votre chauffe et la tension
quand on touche un petit peu ces
dispositifs et c'est pour savons
évidemment
vous êtes
mètres de nous toutes vos réflexions
toutes nos décisions on va se pencher
sur la question je pense dans notre
prochain peau on va s'y pencher sur le
fond il faut toujours faire attention
quand on touche un petit peu ces leviers
ces choses là ces dispositifs parce
qu'il ya parfois des effets secondaires
qu'on allait participer au moment où
vous voulez on les manipule on les
change et donc faut regarder cette
presse ça va nous demander quelques
quelques mois de travail voyez pour bien
voir quelles sont les conséquences
d'une modification entre autres comme
moïse et de la bonification pour donner
un plus grand bénéfice pour les salariés
à temps partiel néanmoins c'est
compliqué ce sont des choses compliquées
galetas dispositifs qui s'accumulent
l'un sur l'autre quand on bouge un
dispositif il faut penser aussi à sa
cohérence avec les autres dispositifs
existants c'est pour ça que encore une
fois le dire que évidemment d'intuition
ahmed radio vous avez raison pour que je
sois le premier euro néanmoins le
réalisme
amène aussi à se dire on est dans un
pays où il ya beaucoup de choses ces
choses là sont d'une complexité inouïe
on a une accumulation le dispositif qui
ont chacun été conçu sans aucune
cohérence avec les autres qui
s'accumulent donc les uns sur les autres
il faut faire attention il faut faire
attention et donc étudiants ça sur le
fond avant de prendre une décision
même si cette décision semble évidemment
conforme à
à l'intuition donc ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose voiliers de
recommandations c'est si vous le
permettez je excusez-moi de
paris comme ça mais nos recommandations
que je ferai à louzy avec prudence et
sur ce plan-là gérer que le travail
puisque vous avez auditionné
monsieur lenglart l'appétit tout à
l'heure le travail qu'il a été fait une
autre aventure vécue par dodo j'en ai
fait moi même sur l'unification des
minima sociaux des plus grands nombres
de mina sociaux c'est vraiment utile aux
france pour d'ailleurs une mort donner
une plus grande visibilité pour amener
les gens à se rendre compte de données
quand tu fais par l'état des charges
globales qui écrit par l'état qui colle
zain et puis ce sera utile aussi bon
pour donner une cohérence à cet ensemble
qui tourne l'instant comme fois n'en a
pas alors l'articulation avec lierre
comme vous le savez ces gens en bas de
chez leurs feintes et dans un pays où il
ya répliqué que par moins de 50% des
foyers fiscaux que là on parle de
personnes qui ne sont pas allées jules à
à l'impôt sur le revenu il faut bien sûr
pensé aussi une cohérence une cohérence
globale mais je dirais que la priorité
des priorités c'est plutôt là la
cohérence entre tous les dispositifs de
soutien aux bas revenus
cette cohérence pour l'instant n'existe
pas n'a jamais été réellement pensé
alors votre dernière question est
importante sur la mobilité salariale
comment on peut faire pour pour
l'augmenter notre l'appétence le cas
d'un mobile id salariale
pour les salariés vous avez raison
complètement raison il faut l'augmenter
on peut pas se satisfaire d'être une
exception avec un faible gain de la
mobilité salariale pour ça il bull
puisque seront nécessaires à mobiliser
la revalorisation la dynamisation de la
négociation collective que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure c'en est une c'est clair
mais ça n'est pas la seule d'autres
pistes c'est bien sûr de se tourner de
se pencher vers la question d'une mise
en cohérence de tous les minima sociaux
et salariaux enfin tous les minima en
termes de revenus toutes les ai toutes
les prestations de façon à éviter des
taux de prélèvement implicite trop
important pour les personnes au bas de
l'échelle et re d'envoyer les directions
que nous que nous évoquons dans notre
rapport du groupe d'experts sont sont
celles-là dynamiser la formation
renforcée donc le le rôle de la
formation mais aussi le rendement de la
formation par la lumière dynamisation la
négociation collective par sortir de
décoller au bout du rouleau comme je
vous ai lleurs plusieurs dispositifs et
puis et puis
par une pensée
dirais-je une refondation des minima
sociaux toujours donner une cohérence
globale et puis pour éviter d autres
éléments épicier qui soit trop fort et
quelquefois un euro de plus de revenus
d'activité abouti à quelque chose très
faible en quarts de l'effectif contenu
la dégressivité du différents
dispositifs qui ont été conscients
dépendamment des uns des autres avec une
bonne intention emmerdé par l'avant mais
les uns des autres voyez ces salles et
les pistes des pistes prioritaires bien
sûr
merci nous allons passer la parole à nos
collègues et 1,3 demandes d'intervention
est le président cette répondra ensuite
alors raymonde poncet mange ensuite
victoire jasmin comme un éclat
vraiment
oui vous retenez merci nouvelle
présidente bonjour je sais j'aurais bien
posé plusieurs questions les ouates le
temps est contraint donc je vais
m'arrêter avec question je poserai sur
votre huitième point tout en disant
toutefois que la corrélation entre
l'existence d'un salaire minimum i la
faiblesse de la négociation collective
nous semble pas toujours
effective puisque l'allemagne je crois
est comme une caractérisée par une
session collective aux fortes etienne a
dessiné d'avoir un salaire minimum est
tout simplement parce que la tendance
est à cela et contrairement peut-être à
cette appréciation puisqu'en novembre
2000 21 le conseil européen et le
parlement ont lancé des négociations
pour l'élaboration d'un salaire minimum
européen dans ce pays au niveau dans un
poisson 16 par rapport à son salaire
indécent par rapport à sa situation et
connaît bien non je voulais revenir son
vous poser une question sur le huitième
point en fait vous dit quelque chose qui
n'est pas nouveau toujours été la
position des économistes d'une majorité
ou
tout le monde que je vois ta tion des
salaires minimums détruire de l'emploi
ont fait
de leur
style à dire quand même que la baisse du
coût de travail à nous montrer qu'elles
ont créés
sur 7 sur cette appréciation
je voulais vous dire mais qu'est ce que
vous pensez de
2,2 du prix nobel du prime du coup
qu'au prix nobel d'économie en 2021
david carne qui conclut à l'absence
d'impact sans fil un effet notable sur
l'emploi de la voie du salaire minimum
ce qui a conduit d'ailleurs des pays aux
fins à augmenter leurs salaires ni même
comme la nouvelle zélande
alors on dirait c'est un phénomène et
ben on a on n'est pas d'accord et
prénovel ce qui est passé d'un pas
toujours d'accord seulement il existe
aussi vous devez savoir une méta analyse
sur 55 études on qui a été réalisée par
une université américaine en 2019 pour
le trésor britannique qui conclut je
sais qu'ils aient une connaissance pour
éteindre un extrait d'un méfait très
très modérée des salaires minimums sont
en bois tout en donnant en annonçant
ciblant les revenus des travailleurs
peut rêver
donc voila et enfin nous c'est pas ça a
été le point
thérèse quand même m'expliquer pour
finir avec les tensions sur loclois et
pourra augmenter dans un certain nombre
de branches où il ya beaucoup de semis
car vous l'avez signalé
il ya toujours une corrélation fait une
forte corrélation entre oscar et temps
partiel puisque ils sont efficaces ont
représenté 3 fois plus dans les temps
partiels alors moi qui fais donc jeanne
d'arese libyen qui font augmenter les
salaires dans ces métiers manche tout ce
que si on veut résoudre le problème de
l'attractivité de ce métier elle était
conditions de travail ma question est
celle là après cet exposé vous vous
convenez d'en mettre dans je crois dans
votre rapport quand une étude
quantitative sur les feuilles de salaire
minimum sur l'emploi il a été conduit au
cours de ces quatre années vous vous
dites toujours un petit peu la même
source sur cette corrélation demande à
notre monde des affaires donc par
rapport au prix nobel par rapport aux 55
études la méta-analyse vous de voir si
vous si vous comptez enfin on mettre à
l'épreuve d'une étude n'est pas
simplement de simulation mais une étude
vraiment
d'autres votre postulat cloud salaire
minimum détruit les emplois je vous
remercie
merci
victor jasmin oui merci mr suivi de
monique lubin merci beaucoup madame la
présidente merci bien sûr pour votre
intervention oui alors je reviendrai sur
un rapport récent de la délégation aux
droits des femmes du sénat concernant
les femmes en milieu rural et la lie à
malgré les dispositifs de droit commun
de grands écarts parce qu'on se rend
compte que les femmes et bien le non pas
forcément des salaires égaux pour les
travaux identiques déjà mais en plus
elles sont payées en ne savent même de
ce qui est prévu par la législation
quand elles ont la chance d'avoir un
travail parce que là aussi il ya un vrai
sujet c'est un vrai sujet et même les
négociations annuelles par exemple
obligatoire moi c'était entreprises là
où ils sont et bien quelquefois ne sont
pas fait
parce que ce sont des femmes parce
qu'elles n'osent pas toujours réclamé
effectivement aujourd'hui et elles sont
la plupart du temps pays en deçà de ce
qui serait
légal je dirais donc les problématiques
liées aussi à la mobilité salariales et
sociales qui a été évoqué par mon
collègue son sol c'est ce sont aussi des
sujets à prendre en compte et voir dans
quelle mesure ils là vous l'avez déjà
plus ou moins évoqué il faudrait il
revoir l'ensemble des dispositifs pour
voir la situation particulière des
femmes parce qu'elles sont celles qui
paient le tribut
contenu
la situation de l'emploi est en fonction
de là où elle habite évidemment parce
qu'elles n'ont pas forcément tous les
toutes les possibilités d'une part dont
programmée de rocco et elles n'osent pas
donc là aussi un problème d'information
et de formation donc je marie thriller
mais je vous remercie en tout cas pour
tout ce que vous nous avez déjà
apporté comme information merci
pour terminer monique le bain et ensuite
présidence être prendra même la
présidente bonjour à tout le monde
moi j'avoue que je suis
un peu interpellé parce que quand je
fais le bilan de ce que vous nous avez
dire qui est très intéressant je ne vois
pas bien de porte de sortie pour parler
de responsabiliser les syndicats
dans le cas des négociations de branche
mais vous savez savons bien que
notamment dans les plus petites
entreprises il n'y a pas un syndicat est
donc quasiment aucune pause
vous dites que les dispositifs publics
coûtent chers et peuvent nuire à la
mobilité professionnelle
que je peux j'ai petit gisement entendre
j'ai envie de dire dans ces cas là que
fait-on pour que ceux qui travaillent
dans les plus petites entreprises
puissent bénéficier
même parcours dire de de carrière en
terme de salaire pas l'horizon et qui
valorisent leur emploi souvent des
emplois quand même au savoir faire de
qualité je ne vois pas bien la porte de
sortie
deuxième question
quels sont les éléments qui font que la
plupart du temps vous ne deviez des pas
pour un coup de pouce au smic
voilà
et hier de faire très froid dans le
bureau de monique lubin
faut arrêter là climat fois
président
oui que je réponds de madame la
présidente et allez-y les questions sont
terminées à les y voilà je vais
commencer par répondre à la première
question de mal à vraiment de pousser
mais vous vous trompez
excusez moi vous vous trompez je dois
vous le dire comme cela quand vous
parlez l'allemagne vous vous trompez
vous dites la négociation collective est
très dynamique forte en allemagne et
pourtant il ya un célèbre militant tan
d'ailleurs les décident de l'augmenter
comme la nouvelle commission comme like
a annoncé récemment et vous vous trompez
raison simple c'est que la négociation
de branche
concernant une fraction sable des
salariés l'irl a négocié les les taux de
couverture par des conventions
collectives concernant l'allemagne
environ environ je vous retrouvez le
chiffre exact si vous le voulez environ
50% des salariés voilà donc les accords
de branche ont donc les grandes qu'à
juste titre en allemagne
ne concerne pas l'autre moitié des
salariés
il faut parler vrai quand on quand on
regarde ces choses-là ces choses là sont
complexes on demande aux parents on peut
pas dire voilà ce qui se passe
maintenant faut regarder attentivement
en france
98 à 99 % des salariés sont couverts par
les négociations tendues pourquoi parce
qu'on a des techniques
d'extension et d'élargissement qui et
automatise en quelque sorte cette
couverture
maximale qu'un est la raison pour
laquelle un salaire minimum a été
instaurée en allemagne à quelques années
c'est justement parce que la négociation
de branche est certes dynamique mais
construire une fraction de plus en plus
faible des salariés et c'est pas pour
cette faiblesse a causé cette faiblesse
que les pouvoirs publics ont décidé
d'instaurer un salaire minimum luc
hessel et les syndicats de salariés nous
y sont plus opposées alors que j opposé
des années précédentes oui c'est ça
l'allemagne c'est ça l'allemagne s'est
pas excusé moi de vous dire ça n'est pas
ce que vous dites alors maintenant dans
les discussions sur les sur la directive
européenne c'est votre deuxième point
vous avez tout à fait raison
les ce qui compte c'est la réalité la
collective alors dans les pays où
n'existe pas un salaire minimum pays
nordiques ce candidat vitali par exemple
des gouvernements d'entendre aucunement
ce programme minimum parce que les
syndicats de salariés n'en veulent pas
en disant c'est un boulot ne nous
affaiblisse et pas dans ces pays là
comme pour les pivots existe un salaire
minimum la directive va essayer
d'instaurer autre chose vous le savez de
toute couverture plus minimales pour
n'est pour les pros du pays tandis
qu'elle n'existait pas un salaire
minimum national et puis le fait que les
salaires minimum qu'ils soient nationaux
ou de branche et bien représente une
certaine fraction du salaire médian sais
c'est la bonne approche c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment la bonne approche c'est
celle vers laquelle on se dirige vous
savez comme moi c'est laval approche est
la vôtre championnat proches n'hésitent
pas il vous faut un salaire ni de quel
rang on dirait au représentant légitime
des salariés qui n'en avaient pas dans
les pays nordiques et scandinaves ou d
instaurer un salaire minimum ces pays là
ils regardent ils disent quoi vous la
france vous allez nous dire qu'il nous
faudrait un salaire minimum national
avec votre taux de chômage plus élevé
que le nôtre avec vos inégalités plus
élevé que le nôtre avec vos problèmes de
compétitivité plus élevé que le nôtre
vous allez nous donner des leçons sur ce
qu'il faut faire ce marché ultra lyon
mais et c'est la raison pour laquelle le
compromis vers lequel on se dirige est
un compromis utile un bon compromis qui
va vraiment ses forces et couvrir les
salariés que ce soit par celle un
minimum national ou que ce soit par des
minima de branche et c'est la bonne
c'est la bonne façon de faire c'est une
façon du nez par dogmatique alors vous
avez raison il ya un prix nobel david
card qui avec un autre économiste kruger
disparu peu de temps d'ailleurs quelques
années avait fait un papier en 1993 de
mémoire nous montrons que aux etats-unis
dans l'industrie de l'alimentation
rapide fast food une augmentation des
salaires minimums pouvait aboutir à des
créations d'emplois s'élevait c'est vrai
et nous avons d'ailleurs dans le rapport
sur le contexte air ça vous a pas
échappé j'imagine
développer énormément l'analyse de cela
des relations entre salaire minimum et
emploi c'était dans le l'avant dernier
ou l'avant-dernier rapports dont celui
de new 19 donc ou celui 2020 je vous
renvoie ça on a un gros chapitre sur
cette question là où on fait une analyse
de des travaux académiques sur la
question voyez on ne fut pas la question
non plus pas la question mon regard sur
le son est donc on explique comment dans
certains cas très spécifique c'est comme
les salaires minimums sont bas ce qui
était le cas et quand les salariés se
retrouvent en situation de monopole
c'est à dire de de relation directe avec
leur employeur bien comment dans ces cas
là les hausses de salaire minimum
peuvent avoir une incidence positive
pour l'emploi pourquoi parce que dans
ces cas là le salaire est très inférieur
peut être très inférieure à la
productivité des effectifs des des
salariés voyez mais on est loin d'être
dans ce cas là en en france on est
plutôt dans la situation de salaire
minimum est élevé et où les situations
de l'obs hommes sont très très rares en
grand jour le jour on voit ce chapitre
ou ou loin de fuir voyez cette ce débat
académique par les prix nobel donc le
débat et la clinique 1 - de fuir ce
débat académique nous le prenons sur le
fond et je suis prêt à discuter quand
vous le voulez de de ce que l'on fait
dans ce la façon dont on rend compte de
ce débat académique 1 et on a les rangs
académique dans notre dans notre groupe
d'experts
alors sur l'analyse quantitative
maintenant dans la france on l'a demandé
on la demandait plusieurs fois j'ai
réussi je vous avoue avoir un budget
pour lancer cette analyse quantitative
des effets sur l'emploi des
modifications du clr vim donc j'ai la
même j'ai la même la même attente que
vous le même désir que vous voyez
maternelle bon c'est bon ça sensible à
ça ça faisait des années j'ai réussi à
obtenir un budget est annoncée donc un
appel à projets de recherche pour dire à
osaka l'ennemi qu'en france à l'étranger
senlis et non une recherche sur les
effets des variations du smic sur
l'emploi qu'est ce que ça pourrait avoir
comme effet sur l'emploi en france alors
on a lancé ça il ya 4 4 5 mois jeudi sa
mémoire on n'est que trois répondre et
puis le comité qui regardait ses
réponses a considéré qu est la mairie
qu'une qui répondait un peu en partie à
la question parce que cette question
n'est pas facile surtout dans un pays
comme la france et c'est plus difficile
qu'aux états unis il ya plein de salaire
minimum ya là un fédéral et puis après
il y en a dans la majorité des états
américains donc les études sont plus
facile d'être en france et c'est assez
dur on a un salaire minimum national
donc voilà il ya une étude qui va
essayer de faire ça et j'espère que dans
notre prochain pour nous on de l'habitat
sur ce point là mais pour les gens six
pages pas sûr que vous allez être
convaincu par part cela parce que
continue des difficultés à étudier ça en
france spécifiques
voilà on va voir si on y arrive et
j'espère et les autres études et là ce
ne ne répondait pas cette a7 à cette
question mais on est tout à fait
sensible à cette à ce souci alors
maintenant quand vous dites que les
allégements de contributions sociales
dans le local effet son emploi alors là
je crois que vous ne trouverez pas un
travail académique sérieux qui ira dans
une direction vous ne pouvez pas dire ça
c'est pas possible de lire ça on ne peut
pas dire ça on peut pas laisser passer
un propos de ce type là je suis
économiste dans ce groupe d expériences
des économies si un sociologue aussi
maintenant
vous ne peut pas laisser passer ça les
économistes
académique ont toujours montré qu elle
un effet sur l'emploi favorable sur
l'emploi sur l'emploi des plus démunis
des gens les moins formés un effet
favorable des allègements de
contributions sociales maintenant la
marche d'évaluation et est pas est pas
évidente elle peut être et peut être
assez large mais il ne fait aucun doute
dans la littérature économique digne de
ce nom car l'effet positif et un large
effets positifs je peux vous dire que
les 25 milliards environ qui sont
dépensés dans les aides au logement
généraux contributions sociales entre 1
et 1,6 smic aboutissent à la
préservation de l'emploi de nombreuses
personnes qui sont fragiles maintenant
est ce que est ce que le nom de ces
personnes et te regarde la somme
de la somme en question
c'est une autre discussion mais que les
faits soient positifs et massive on veut
pas de discuter excusez moi est vraiment
je suis prêt à répondre à toutes les
questions a participé à toutes les
auditions sur les travaux précis sérieux
qui montrerait le contraire c'est pas
possible ça n'existe pas
il faut être très très clair sur cette
chose là bas la victoire excusez moi
peut-être que je déforme votre nom et
j'étais vraiment je m'en excuse
les
imams de jasmin sur le non respect du
smic dans le rapport sur les dernières
années on l'a regardé cette question est
ce qu'il ya de nombreux cas de non
respect du smic et dans la rémunération
des salariés de notre une blague on joue
dans notre milieu
on l'a dans les salles alors en
sollicitant pour sa direction générale
quatre ans plus tôt pour ça qu'ils
l'institut national de la statistique
pour les statistiques précises voyez la
direction charles du travail pour
l'intervention les interventions de
l'inspection du travail qui vérifie sur
le terrain et puis l'institut national
des statistiques pour les données
qui peuvent nous apporter qui permet
nous permet de vérifier le respect ou
pas on aboutit à des présomptions de non
respect du smic très faible très rare
néanmoins cette ce travail est fragile
difficile je vous le concède et de
l'aveu même des personnes qui nous ont
aidés dans cette analyse des risques en
jalles trail l'insee il faut prendre ça
avec des pincettes ce pas faciles à
étudier mais toutes et tous les éléments
d'informations qu'on a pu réunir
voiliers de la part d'institutions comme
la dg travail qui vont sur le terrain
ont d'autres bas qui réunissent tout
esthétique ce pôle il amène à penser et
encore une fois avec prudence que ça
serait très réduite d'un trajet plus les
chiffres en tête je pourrais vous les
donner mais c'est dans l'un de nos
quatre derniers 4,2 à
damier tel talent du rapport alors sur
dernière question madame monique lubin
compte tenu de ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure vous voyez la négociation de
branche compte tenu des techniques très
spécifique à la france
d'extension et d'élargissement
qu'aboutisse à un taux de couverture de
98 99 ans après près de 100% des
salariés par des conventions collectives
même dans des entreprises où il n'y a
pas de représentant syndical il n'y a
pas de syndicat il ya des défis ce bien
sûr de la négociation de branche pour
cette raison pour ce taux de couverture
vous voyez les gars les syndicats qui
leur a dit avoir une absence de présence
syndicale l'absence c'était des
syndicats dans une petite entreprise
certaines entreprises
néanmoins au niveau des branches il ya
la présence de syndicats c'est clair et
cette présence des syndicats permet
justement de couvrir l'ensemble des
salariés y compris dans les entreprises
où il n'y a pas de syndicat et a quand
même deux mouvements qui sont encore
temps de le signaler l'un qui est en
cours et l'autre qui est souhaitable le
premier mouvement c'est que quand
dynamiser la négociation de granger
excusez moi j'aurais dû dire tout à
l'heure il ya un mouvement en france 2
de contraction du nombre de branches qui
est en cours depuis 1922 puis 2013 2014
est d'ailleurs pierre ramin le directeur
général du travail à a joué un grand
rôle dans cette réflexion et dans ceux
dans ce mouvement puisque en france il
ya un nombre de branches énorme une
atomisation des branches qui rendait
parfois complètement virtuel la
négociation collective au niveau des
manches bien on est passé d'environ 700
branche environ 200
par le regroupement de plein plein plein
grange ce processus maintenant qui vient
plus compliqué puisque les branches
sacralité ne reste poursuit il faudrait
qu'il soit poursuivi pour arriver à un
ou deux branches plus faibles et semble
de branges plus faible présenterait
comme avantage
de permettre de faciliter une réalité la
négociation collective au niveau des
branches voyez c'est là aux siens un des
moyens de dynamiser la négociation de
branche ou les hausses salariales comme
dans ce domaine des qualifications les
conditions de travail la formation et
c'est tout ce que vous pouvez avoir en
tête donc il faut absolument de ce
côté-là aussi se rapprocher des autres
pays d'allemagne à moins de 100 branche
pas il faudrait se rapprocher de la
situation allemande où la situation
d'autres grands pays réduire notre
nombre de branches pour renforcer le
rôle de la négociation et l'effectivité
voiliers du rôle de la négociation
collective deux manches alors ça ne veut
pas dire qu'il faut se désintéresser de
ce qui se passe dans les entreprises et
la juste un point j'enlève ma casquette
de président du groupe d'experts sur le
smic je suis intervenu à plusieurs
reprises sur cette question là avec un
juriste qui s'appelle que me connaissez
sans doute nombreux à peu des parts et
demi pour dire qu'il faut davantage
challenge et la présence syndicale et
l'action syndicale dans les entreprises
et qui a des moyens pour cela et
peut-être que le renforcement du rôle du
cso comité social économique dans la
négociation collective les ans la
représentation du collectif de travail
pourrait permettre une dynamisation de
la négociation collective en trotteur
salariales dans les entreprises et dans
les petits entreprise mais là encore une
fois je vous en parlerai dans un autre
contexte puisque vous m'interrogez en
tant que président du groupe d'experts
sur le son voilà voilà j'espère avoir
répondu ah ah c'est à ces éléments mais
pour revenir sur la question de madame
raymonde poncet bon et la france
associée à toute couverture réseau
quelques choses très contradictoires
toute couverture énorme 98 99 % des
salariés sont couverts par les
conventions collectives à la réalité la
négociation collective très fin il ya
une certaine déresponsabilisation des
acteurs de la négociation collective au
niveau des branches c'est clair voilà
évoqué voilà vous qui tout à l'heure et
en allemagne par contre les négociations
collectives de branche centres et un
taux de couverture très faible très
faible qui légitime la création qui a
été décidé d'un salaire minimum dans ce
pays attend évidemment couvrir les
salariés qui ne bénéficient pas de la
couverture de d'une convention
collective de branche voilà j'espère
avoir été clair
merci beaucoup
excusez moi du caractère cash d'une
réponse de mes réponses mais je pense
que c'est plus utile de répondre à 100
vous direct et des naissances en mettre
une structure pour que le débat soit moi
qui rassure ces questions
bon bah écoute et merci beaucoup
et
une autre fois peut-être à une autre
audition en tout cas merci pour ces
réponses sont en effet très cash je suis
à disposition et je me déroberai jamais
à toute demande à une quelconque du
manque de votre part parce que ça c'est
important
merci beaucoup et bon rétablissement
[Musique]